[Musica]
di vivere con un dollaro al giorno ho
visto soffoca di cervelli adesso puoi
smetterla di vivere con un grammo al
giorno
Ciao ragazzi benvenuti in una nuova
puntata di vita buttata sono qui in
compagnia dei Pampers voglio fare una
cosa davvero un amico ok offrirvi subito
qualcosina da bere Io so che uno di voi
ama un gin particolare No non avete il
bobbis Sì perché sapevamo che ci tiene
tanto
Spero che ti piaccia piacere perché è
stato un investimento Questa è
l'edizione limitatissima Tra l'altro
cioè è una roba che non è come quella
merda del tankeri Eh sì non so che cosa
sia successo
naturalmente raga Fermi tutti tutto
finto Cioè sembra sigillato un gin tonic
che vi andrebbe bene Perfetto allora
questo per te ok E poi Andrei adesso
aggiungiamo per te e questo lo
aggiungiamo Per me ok te lo apro coi
denti oppure no aspetta so già lui fa
così come per dire vediamo fin dove è
alto arriva e poi possiamo andare sotto
con lo scoppio
questo tappeto ne ha viste di ogni cosa
ripetere
ragazzi una zolletta 1 o 2 una abbiamo
rotto il ghiaccio bene
direi che siamo pronti per una puntata
di vita buttata
[Musica]
una volta che sono ubriacato così tanto
che poi sono tornato a casa mi sono
buttato nel letto del mio coinquilino
abbracciandolo per poi scoprire che era
un ragazzo che si era appena portato a
letto e il mio coinquilino era in bagno
avventura interessante
noi ci siamo conosciuti sul 7 di Fuga di
cervelli Ok tutto lo ricordi Beh ci sono
state grandi avventure su quel set Luca
ti va di parlarne un secondo decido dopo
una notte di bagordi di dormire di
fianco al mio camerino sul set dorme in
macchina vicino alla roulotte per dire
così anche se mi chiamano all'ultimo
Sono già qua sveglia mi sveglio nella
mia macchina faccio che si sono più o
meno così mi chiamano da 7 mi dicono
dove sei Stai arrivando Io faccio Sto
arrivando metto in moto la macchina e
parto e me ne vado da sempre era già lì
è la cosa più importante Infatti per
migliorare è quella di non rendersi
conto di questi errori e per quanto mi
riguarda tu ci sei riuscito No te l'ho
detto sono cresciuto un po' di te lo
prendo ancora
è cambiato ragazzi Questo è ancora nella
nostra vita auguri ciao ospiti volevo
raccontare vi dico subito
ho visto un'ambulanza e ho deciso che
stavo male anche io e quindi ho
costretto una mia amica a portarmi in
ospedale al pronto soccorso e quindi mi
hanno messo in quel corridoio e poi dove
mettono tutta la gente aspettare di
venir visitate e c'era una signora che
correva con trombone Io ho cominciato a
ridere in faccia il giorno non ho capito
nemmeno io sapevo che l'effetto placebo
curasse non ammalasse cioè un'ambulanza
Oddio Eh ma l'ambulanza non per lei
l'amica stava male Deve fingere di stare
male vedevo una delle scoregge diciamo
Vi ringrazio per questo mio studio
perché credo che sia stato puntuale
forse veramente sei cambiato eh
dovrei essere un nome dal liceo in preda
ad una non so che cosa voglio fare di
follia vede un nipote per il quale avevo
mai una cotta pazzesca e addolorata e
gli dico mille di questi giorni
no non ci credo io credo in quel momento
ti scoreggino le orecchie e come quando
ti piace una persona ci pensi così e poi
ti fai sempre il figo e sei perfetto con
le persone di cui non te ne frega un
cazzo è incredibile
Se sei te stesso Non puoi essere
perfetto però Sei sempre perfetto
figurati di merda Ragazzi io ne ho una
reale una persona a me molto vicina
Ultima fila io davanti vedo lo strazio
la tragedia Purtroppo la tragedia ci
vuole poco per trasformarla in un
qualcosa di estremamente comico e questo
prete che fa un'omelia di speranza e
conclude con una cosa che era tipo ma
purtroppo è morto e ormai è un cadavere
ridevo come le aquile cioè io ho dovuto
fingere di piangere
[Musica]
nel 2016 muore mia madre da un momento
all'altro da un momento Esatto
a tennis 8 ore 10 ore dopo è morta in
ospedale Ok mi vibra al telefono Tony
ragon Ciao Pisa hai notizie sulla mamma
di Luca sì sì a casa sta bene è riuscito
a farmi proprio ridere No già non è un
messaggio facile da mandare in generale
perché in quel momento il telefono lo
voglio mandare via non è un attimo mi
fermo un signore un ragazzino mi fa
occupare una foto con te Certo faccio Ok
a posto no E lui mi pare sono Vincenzo
Scusa non mi ricordo la quinta
grazie grazie
della nazionale italiana Oh che cazzo ne
so di calcio oh capito ma i mondiali Li
abbiamo visti tutti anch'io non so come
artista perché mi metteva l'ansia
vederli Vincevamo o perdevamo No io se
non guardo le partite vinciamo
altrimenti soprattutto
da leggere perché da quando sono piccolo
e soprattutto svegliato che me la fai
tagliare giuro grandi e allora volevo
tornare a Napoli Buonasera ragazzi
abbiamo la sveglia alle 3:00 di notte e
tipo era tutta ubriaca che farò così
tutta bianca ai video che stava nel taxi
mezza nuda io ti vogliamo chiesto che
casca dal successo e poi son venuto a
sapere da amiche sue che si era
ubriacata perché ha regalato il vestito
un'amica sua solamente perché lei gli
aveva detto che gli piaceva quindi lei
deve punta bianca in mezzo alla sala
spogliata tutta te gli ha regalato il
vestito e io ho capito una cosa che a
Genovesi da fare però cosa non nel caso
mio padre io mi sono fermato a Jacopo
Forse è il mio preferito Chi è che porta
avanti la baracca la nonna
ah ah Tu cerchi Romano tre sinonimi esce
la sua faccia domanda curiosità mia
Quali sono i preconcetti capito quello
che si pensa dei romani Io sono molto
ferrato in generale sui preconcetti
perché sto con una fidanzata sono una
fidanzata che è casualmente fidanzata
con me
mi è piaciuta fin da subito L'unico
problema per me era che era Romana ci
scontriamo sempre perché lei mi dice Ma
la smetti di avere sti pregiudizi sulla
gente in generale Cioè io non sto
dicendo tutti i romani sono perché
questo è un errore ma dire
tendenzialmente un romano è è vero se la
tirano No non è che se la tirano cazzo
amplificano e tutto a 5 minuti ok 5
minuti come dice un romano stava a 5
minuti
[Risate]
il pregiudizio non è mai sbagliato
È brutto quando diventa una totale una
totale Una totalità del quel concetto
non so cosa sta dicendo
è un Bobby che non ti permettere Mamma
mia posso sapere un attimo una cosa però
giusto perché così almeno Nessuno mi dà
racconto sui torinesi che c'è Allora su
Torino si dice sempre Torinese falso
Cortese è vero Il Torinese ti dirà no Ma
figurati Non c'è problema poi si gira e
Minchia in famiglia dice il caso Però
hai visto che invadente mentre per loro
c'è Luca che sta suonando prima cosa
stava scordata E noi siamo
tranquillissimo segmento
[Musica]
il gioco è molto semplice Ragazzi
abbiamo Andrea contro Luca Per gli amici
Jacopo
Dovete usare degli insulti forbiti in un
certo senso strutturale strutturatissima
Andrea ti ringrazio penso che tu sei un
bel [ __ ]
[Musica]
sei più inutile della gricia col
pomodoro vuole intortarsi i romani lui e
poi era bruttissimo anche per un romano
quando vai a prendere il treno i barboni
ti dicono posso darti qualcosa
sei più stupido di una tipo che regalo
il vestito una che glielo chiedi e più
riconoscibile Iaquinta per strada
sai che sul palco fai più cagare di
questo Jim Chinotto cazzo Comunque hai
già 13 anni di carriera Pensa con delle
idee
anche tu hai 15 anni di carriera pensavo
fosse merito tuo sai che a te che suoni
Preferisco un pezzo di tana Nike io devo
dire una cosa o il vincitore
il vincitore di questo match ed è per
questo che ti propongo una finale contro
di me posso avere il gin e basta
Sono veramente orgoglioso di avere la
possibilità di fare questa sfida con il
proprietario di questo canale
dov'è guldo
sono veramente orgogliosi di poter fare
questa sfida con il membro divertente
dei Panpers È un peccato non averti
davanti
Secondo me dovevi interpretare il morto
tu in fuga di cervelli ha interpretato
Luca Ed è stato questo il motivo per cui
è stato l'ultimo film ma non è vero Mi
piace molto questa camicia non so se la
vita buttata cucina buttato delle
canzoni Mi piace molto che tu abbia
tolto il cartone per venire invece
ah ah ah
durante tu hai letto quel periodo lì tu
facevi la parodia
ispirato il discorso del succhiare
solo una battuta sulla omosessualità
ragazzi nel momento in cui finiamo
Comunque il Gin possiamo sempre
succhiare il sangue di Luca ti ho visto
una Pechino Express Però la puoi
smettere di vivere con un dollaro al
giorno e ho visto soffoca di cervelli
adesso puoi smetterla di vivere con un
grammo al giorno ti ho visto sugli altri
Ah no non eri tu
Bravissimo Io avrei riso Il problema è
che non ci avevi Andrea che ti imboccava
giusto che pensi di essere di nuovo sul
set di fuori dei cervelli No penso di
essere sul set per cui il fatto che gli
attori sono sbronzi è l'unico motivo per
cui funziona Jacopo non essere così Che
cattivo cattivo
ma devo decidere io quando è finita per
me è finita ragazzi un'altra sfida di
villanie a caso termina qui come
concludiamo sempre un saluto a tutti
[Applauso]
non è per galanteria ma vince il padrone
di casa Grazie grazie mille
ascoltiamo un altro messaggio Eh già che
questo è il format Spero in attesa per
andare dal medico mi viene un attacco di
diarrea fulminante proprio Brividi di
sudore decido di tornarmene a casa ma
non riesco ad arrivare neanche alla
macchina che sento che sto per esplodere
perciò decido di farla dentro un
sacchetto dietro le sedili posteriori
della mia auto Io metto una cosa adesso
stavo cercando durante le riprese di
Colorado faccio vedere scorregge
bellissimo
A un certo punto
A un certo punto una macchinetta così
metto la macchinetta così Vabbè dai
guerra mi sono cacato mi è esploso il
culo
Scusate mi spiego subito una cosa se
ride lui la vostra battuta meno 5 punti
se ride lui colorato
se ride lui Siete in una buona
percentuale se ride lui Occhio che non
ride nessuno cioè Siamo troppo elevati
vado in camerino
[Risate]
le butto per sempre Allora la mia più
grande figura di merda è stata che
dopo un viaggio in treno con un'amica di
famiglia dove mi ha raccontato che
praticamente sua suocera stava molto
male
insomma per per passare l'altro mondo Io
quando arrivo in stazione che ci
salutiamo Dove appunto lei va dalla
suocera in ospedale Io me ne vado via Le
dico condoglianze
Peccato che non era mancata la suocera
Io me lo ricordo vado nel panico e in
mezzo al panico riesco ad aggiungere per
quando sarà cioè volevo stare io sotto
mezzo metro di tempo Non ce ne frega un
cazzo allora
[ __ ]
sai fare questo fermo l'altro dammi
quella Ecco io ti do Eccolo ci dispiace
per la tua figuraccia
verde non è carino perché bisogna
ascoltarla
regà Luca era caricatura di un ubriacone
Ciao Gu Ciao ospiti
dopo un viaggio in treno con un'amica di
famiglia dove mi ha raccontato che
praticamente sua suocera stava molto
male e stava per passare l'altro mondo
Io quando arrivo in stazione che ci
salutiamo Dove appunto lei va dalla
suocera in ospedale Io me ne vado via Le
dico condoglianze
non era mancata la suocera Io me lo
ricordo vado nel panico e in mezzo al
panico riesco ad agire per quando sarà
No no no
Complimenti No bravo
poverina Poverina allora partiamo già da
un presupposto che condoglianze
veramente una parola Difficile da dire
Diciamo a chi guarda un suggerimento al
posto di condoglianze secondo me c'è
un'alternativa pazzesca mi dispiace un
sacco
sono d'accordo questo qui è uno di quei
momenti nei quali tu fai Fail su tutto
Cioè tu hai un momento in cui tu stai
sbagliando dopo
Io preferisco chiamare allora
ero al mare con dei miei amici in
vacanza e dopo una giornata di alcolismo
molto pesante decidiamo di andare a
ballare e niente Finisce che io sbatto
addosso Una ragazza col vestito rosso
che scappa via piangendo Sono contenta
di tutto ciò cerco di raggiungere i miei
amici ma nel tragitto venire di nuovo
venuto da vomitare cercando di
nascondermi dal buttafuori ho beccato
con il naso lo spigolo di un tavolino
mentre vomitavo quindi mi sono messo
spaccata al naso per cui ho fatto
l'ultimo tragitto verso i miei amici
vomitando e perdendo sangue dal naso
posso dire dov'è la telecamera
come mai ce l'hai storto tu un mio
compagno nel liceo gli ruba il
portapenne il portapenne sarebbe
l'astuccio No zio porco cane cioè che
cos'è il 42 tasti il pianoforte
la zampetta sarebbe il lo sgabello
ragazzi che mi piacciono ma dovrebbe
cazzo parlare Vabbè ok a 5 minuti Allora
devi fare le trappetta io sbatto il
setto nasale sul terrore di marmo Ok che
era un corridoio non mi si sta generando
dal momento colsetto deviato sei un tipo
senza stare brutto e basta ragazzi dopo
tre ore di Shooting non so quante ne
vedrete voi alla fine a casa spero molte
di meno Io ringrazio
iPantellas siete stati i miei ospiti No
a parte gli scherzi Grazie Pampers per
essere arrivati
meravigliosi che poi tra parentesi in
questo momento siete anche in tourné
giustamente Siamo intorno incredibile
Dove possiamo vedere le date su
panpers.it perché ci hanno rubato
proprio per punto com Mmm non ci credo
una cherata adesso ci sono fatti vuoti
nelle foto dei vecchi che vedi sono
addosso però su Panpers tour.it possiamo
scoprire le vostre date perfetto Ragazzi
grazie mille per averci seguito grazie
mille Pampers per essere stati i miei
ospiti noi ci vediamo sempre qui non so
quando ma prima o poi succederà Ciao